this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description that get 20% off of their
annual premium subscription self-driving
cars are coming maybe in two years maybe
in 20 but some day the steering wheel
will fade into history like jell-o salad
and these weird coasters the elderly and
disabled will have cheap convenient
transportation instead of racing to work
you'll sit back relax and generate ad
revenue for me and crashes we'll go from
unfortunate reality to rare tragedy when
three technologies converge self-driving
electric and shared cars the problem of
how to get from A to B will pretty much
be solved for the 68% of us living in
cities there will be no need to own a
car in this world the transportation is
a service waiting on every street corner
nuke and alley no waiting hailing or
repairing of course convenience is
nothing new the real force of progress
is economic without the cost of drivers
and gasoline prices fall dramatically
they won't just be faster easier safer
and you know better for the planet
or whatever but also affordable for
everyone the car will become the ideal
form of transport not despite its cost
but in part because of it and that's the
problem more cars means more congestion
more parking more challenges for cities
you might be thinking sure and
automation can solve them
perhaps but mass transportation is a
very complicated and political equation
it's not that self-driving cars are bad
exactly the opposite it's that so much
optimism hides real obstacles or at the
very least question marks on the road to
the city of the future
like many technologies individually
self-driving cars are great collectively
they have all kinds of unexpected
consequences everything about them we
hear through the lens of technology and
when you're a programmer everything
looks like Ruby on Rails to really
understand them we need the mindset of a
Sim City professional and at the top of
things
urban planners hate our highways parking
lots wide roads and suburbs basically
cars or everything America is obsessed
with today electric vehicles make up
less than 1% of new car sales in the
u.s. even in Norway where it's 22%
that's only 84,000 electric compared to
1 billion a total in other words were a
long ways away from most cars being
electric until then they release a 13%
of all greenhouse gas kill more people
from pollution than crashes and make
cities look and sound like well this but
even if every car were electric tomorrow
and self-driving technology was perfect
and everyone could afford it there's
still a fundamental problem space the
most valuable resource in a dense urban
area 60 people commuting to work can
look like this or it can look like this
if we're generous and assume two people
per car that's still not 60 imagine how
wasteful sidewalks would be if everyone
required a two meter buffer well you
don't have to fine you say so we'll
build more and bigger roads do not pass
go and do not collect $200 this is a
classic mistake because bigger roads do
work just only for a minute as roads
improve more people drive until it's
just as busy as it was before bigger
roads more traffic same congestion
remember transportation is an ecosystem
you can pull any levers you want end
with the best intentions but change one
variable and three dominoes down the
line who knows what happens trust me
I watch levers get pulled all the time
plus money spent on roads isn't spent
improving
trains bikes and buses so why do roads
get bigger anyway
in part because politicians serve as
short terms reduce commute time get
reelected and then watch it returned to
normal roads determine the shape health
and success of a city they push
buildings further apart and housing into
suburbs these long distances between
home and work or school or shopping
encourage and often require the use of a
car what could be an easily walked or
bike community is stretched out into an
endless sea of buildings or people get
less exercise make fewer friends even
spend less money but for 92% of their
life cars just sit in the US alone there
are 1 billion parking spaces 4 times the
number of cars or together the size of
Connecticut most cities have parking
minimums for example a bowling alley in
San Jose California must provide at
least 7 parking spaces per bowling lane
a business office requires one for every
250 square feet but a research office
only 300 which is just as arbitrary as
it sounds in 2004 the City of London
removed these minimums and parking fell
from 1.1 spaces per apartment to 0.6 and
since businesses are incentivized to
create as much parking as customers need
this switch from free to free market
parking shows there was previously too
much of course parking is never really
free in residential areas it hides in
the cost of rent in the u.s. that's an
average of 225 a month sometimes much
more and taxpayers bear the cost of free
public parking whether they use it
everyday or can't afford a car and only
breathe in their fumes worse Americans
incentivize driving with a federal
commuter tax benefit 7.3 billion dollars
a year in write-offs for those who drive
to work this alone causes an estimated
4.6 billion more miles to be driven and
moves wealth from poor to rich meanwhile
the government loses 7 billion dollars
which I have a feeling it could find a
better use for now you might be thinking
all this talk of parking and sprawl and
roads it assumes more cars in the future
but when we share them won't there
actually be fewer
well maybe but there's good reason to be
skeptical for every mile shared uber and
lyft rides
save they add 2.6 how is that possible
45 percent of the time at their empty
driving to and from pickups and 60
percent of riders say they would have
otherwise walked or biked or stayed home
driverless cars will be more efficient
but not fundamentally different there
will be empty wasted miles and many who
share will do so instead of a more
efficient means of transportation and
because demand fluctuates they'll still
need parking having enough cars to get
everyone to and from work leaves many
with nothing to do for the rest of the
day they could go park outside the city
but that means more miles driven plus
they all need somewhere for recharging
cleaning and maintenance now here's the
thing it's easy to imagine a future
where automation is so efficient none of
this really matters for example this
study estimates the 25 to 35 percent
increase in traffic flow which is very
encouraging here's the catch only when
nearly every vehicle is self-driving
eventually cars will no longer have the
monkey coordination problem where one
car can slow down a city but that's the
key
it only takes a single non self-driving
car even with 75% driverless the study
says the improvements are minor so
someday they may solve the
transportation problem but first they
could make it much worse the most
efficient way to travel isn't the car or
train or plane it's your feet minimal
infrastructure and a very small well
footprint almost as good are bicycles
and skateboards of course these alone
are not enough so transportation is a
balance it's not bus versus rail versus
car but all of the above when twice a
day five days a week thousands of people
need to get from roughly here to roughly
here well you're probably looking for
Rapid Transit within the city where
routes and demand change over time the
bus is probably your answer but
self-driving cars threaten this balance
the first to adopt them will be those
that can afford it and as more and more
upper and middle class disappear from
public transit so will its funding
disappear to them a public
will seem old and unnecessary but it'll
still be very important for much of the
population
if cities want to keep an efficient
balance they need to prioritize
accordingly designing first for walking
and biking open spaces clean sidewalks
and instead of fighting the homeless
well maybe fighting homelessness after
that encouraging public transit the most
efficient cost-effective way to move
huge groups of people and finally
controlling the number of cars making
sure drivers themselves pay their costs
including those you can't see the price
of tolls and parking should increase
with demand creating an incentive not to
drive and managing congestion during
peak hours none of this will be easy but
ultimately transportation is an equation
the difference between an overcrowded
city and a comfortable one is finding
the optimal mathematical solution cities
have to find the right balance of old
technologies and new ones like dhoklas
electric scooters bike sharing even
segways and speaking of segways a great
way to learn the math behind cities and
the computer science enabling
self-driving cars is with brilliant org
if you enjoy solving puzzles like what's
the most efficient way to layout a
subway network or figuring out how to
use probability to win games you'd
probably love brilliant here the way you
learn is by doing not just memorizing
you solve a puzzle or play with a graph
learn the concepts behind it then check
your understanding it gives you the
skills to solve real useful problems and
just as importantly it does so in a way
you'll actually understand for me that's
what's satisfying not just being able to
use an equation but explain how it works
and use that knowledge to create
something new there are enough topics
that you can explore whatever interests
you most
machine learning astronomy computational
biology and a whole lot more you can
check it out yourself for free and
support this channel with a link in the
description brilliant org slash poly
matter and the first 200 people will get
20% off the annual premium subscription
earlier in this video we talked about
transportation incentives that topic
deserves more attention and it's the
subject of a new video on the YouTube
channel city beautiful I highly
recommend checking out all his videos
he does a really great job explaining
city related topics in an entertaining
way and there's nothing quite like it on
YouTube link is in the description and
thanks for listening